à travers chance est un chapelet mortel
qui ces graines dans les prairies du sud
de l'Ukraine
identifiées par de simples fanions
rouges et blanc d'innombrables mi nous
munitions non explosé jonge très et
bas-côtés
au volant de son tracteur volo Dimir a
déjà été blessé à deux reprises depuis
ce début mai il a roulé sur deux engins
explosifs à 5 jours d'intervalle
cette guerre n'a pas de faim les côtes
meurtriers la peur au ventre mais
reprendre l'activité coûte que coûte
c'est bon tout va bien le lendemain
j'étais de retour au travail bien sûr
que cela m'effraie et tout le monde
était effrayé mais nous devons le faire
nous avons peur quand nous travaillons
dans les champs quand nous nous
déplaçons sur les chemins et qu'on nous
rentrons chez nous
puis au beau Mirka a été pendant trois
mois sur la ligne de front ou un mot
leur est à la reconstruction
Ivan et sa famille possède 700 hectares
son cheptel a été volé pendant les six
mois d'occupation russe et les combats
qui ont permis la libération de la
région de Carson ont laissé sur son
exploitation des carcasses calcinées des
caisses de munitions et des champs se
mélangent de mort comme nombre
d'agriculteurs Ukrainiens ils se
débrouille par lui-même quitte à déminer
de façon artisanale
nous avons acheté des détecteurs de
métaux et nous avons marché à plusieurs
à travers nos champs séparés de cinq six
mètres et nous continuons à le faire
dans un champ de 30 hectares on peut
récupérer de quoi remplir une remorque
entière d'obus
quand nous sommes face à des obus de
tank ou des roquettes grades au sol ce
n'est pas aussi dangereux que là où ils
ont posé des mines antichards
en explosif Yvan et ses amis font le tri
entre les obus et ventes et ce non
explosé
quitte parfois des miner à mains nues
la moitié de cet air serait désormais
selon lui dépollué prête pour Kandra il
ouvriers scène des cultures tardives
voilà les graines de tournesol acheter à
crédit un pari sur l'avenir pour espérer
que 15 mois de guerre finissent enfin
d'altérer le rythme et les récoltes
pouvaient être déminées cet été car cet
automne nous devons planter de nouveau
et dans un ou deux ans les mines vont
s'enfoncer plus profondément dans le sol
et alors quand serons-nous capables de
déminer
mais tous n'ose pas comme Yvan retourner
aux champs les trois quarts des surfaces
des environs resteront en jachère
c'est l'or noir de l'Ukraine avant
l'invasion russe le pays était le
quatrième exportateur mondial de
céréales et de lesagineux un secteur
essentiel puisqu'il représente 20% du
PIB national mais ici dans le sud la
plupart des champs ne seront pas semés
pour la deuxième année consécutive